ja ich begrüße alle zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer zu hören und zuhören dieses
barcamps und ich möchte heute mal ein
bisschen was erzählen
zum thema vernetzen und verstehen
strukturelle virtuelle lehre was ist das
wie sehen virtueller strukturen aus und
ich möchte dazu ein bisschen was aus
meiner eigenen erfahrung richten
die entscheidende frage lautet wie
lassen sich digitale medien strukturell
didaktisch in die lehre integrieren und
mit leerem eine ich jetzt jede form der
lehre also sowohl lehre in der
grundschule lehre auf den ford bildenden
gymnasien erwachsenenbildung
hochschullehre damit meine ich lehre
generell das ist eine frage eine weitere
frage die man jetzt hier noch stellen
kann lautet sind digitale medien nicht
eigentlich nur überflüssiges spielzeug
in der lehre diesen vorwurf hört man
häufig das ist nur so schnickschnack das
soll die ganze sache ein bisschen
aufpeppen aber es hat nicht wirklich
sinn und es fügt sich auch nicht
wirklich in die traditionelle lehre und
ich werde in meinem kurzen impuls
beitrag die frage verneinen ich werde
die these vertreten dass digitale medien
nicht nur spielzeug sind sondern sehr
sinnvolle ergänzungen darstellen
vielleicht sogar auch transformationen
der traditionellen lehre und ich werde
zeigen wie genau das realisiert werden
kann
ich sagte schon ein bisschen was zu
meiner person ich habe damit schon
einige erfahrungen gemacht ich habe
diese der projekte die ich jetzt
vorstellen möchte an der lmu münchen als
mitarbeiter in den letzten vier jahren
realisiert und dabei sehr viel gelernt
das wurde gefördert von lehrer lmu und
das ist auch gefällt werden von
multiplikatoren projekte lmu münchen und
letztendlich auch vom bundesministerium
für bildung
ich selbst habe auch ein unternehmen
gegründet das heißt die gidag ticks
diesem jahr in dem ich selbst
dienstleistungen zur verfügung stelle
die aus meiner eigenen erfahrung
erwachsen sind
zunächst möchte ich einen ganz wichtigen
unterschied hier mal thematisieren
nämlich den unterschied zwischen
simulation und virtualität häufig denkt
man wenn man virtualität hört oder auch
virtuelle realität hört dann denkt man
ein so eine brille
das ist der gemeine begriff die gemeinde
begriffs verwendung das ist eine
virtuelle 3d brille simulations- brille
und ich glaube dass uns ein solches
verständnis von virtueller realität in
die irre führt auch mit blick auf die
leere warum ich bin der auffassung und
einige andere denkerin und denker auch
das virtualität nicht der gegensatz von
realität bedeutet also nicht nur
illusion oder so eine simulation die wir
eingegeben bekommen sondern ich bin der
auffassung dass virtualität selbst eine
form von realität ist also virtualität
sollten wir nicht gegen realität
ausspielen
und wenn das so ist wie ich jetzt
glauben einige andere auch dann stellt
sich die frage wie können wir aus losen
simulationen virtuelle welten werden
lassen dass sie ganz spannende frage
weil diese frage kann man auch auf die
lehre anwenden
das ist dann die frage nach der
virtualität der lehre gibt es so was wie
eine virtuelle lehre
jetzt gibt es eine weitere wichtige
unterscheidung die man die
unterscheidung zwischen digitalisierung
und digitalität nennen könnte
digitalisierung meint die technische
durchführung von digitalisierungs
prozessen also wenn ich zum beispiel
bücher in den scanner legen und dann ein
ocr optical character recognition
verfahren darüber laufen lassen dann
digitalisiert ich etwas die digitalität
ist ihr die virtuelle realität der
digitale
sierung oder auch die kulturelle seite
das wäre dann das wie ich das gewonnene
digitalisat ganz sinnvoll für bestimmte
zwecke transformative einsetzen kann
das geht dann über in die virtuelle
realität man sieht hier schon
digitalisierung wäre es digitalität
hängt ganz eng zusammen mit der frage
nach der virtuellen realität
das wird mich zu der entscheidenden
frage nach der digitalität der lehre wie
genau können wir uns jetzt digitale
lehre vorstellen oder virtuelle lehre
fest steht dass sich struck die
strukturelle realisierung der virtuellen
realität in der lehre behaupten muss das
heißt wir müssen zeigen können wie wir
das digitale die das virtuelle so in die
lehre integrieren dass es naht not
nahtlos übergeht dass es keine brüche
gibt sondern dass es sich der struktur
der lehre anpasst und das ist die
entscheidende frage und jetzt gibt es
verschiedene möglichkeiten wie man das
digitale oder auch das virtuelle
strukturell in die lehre integrieren
kann da sind zum beispiel blogs das sind
wikis vor allem hypertext hypertext sind
vernetzungs strukturen die sich
besonders gut durch digitalisierung
realisieren lassen man kennt das von
wikipedia
dann sind das eps dann ist das youtube
und so weiter und ich möchte ihnen jetzt
ganz kurz ein paar konkrete beispiele
demonstrieren die ich entwickelt habe um
zu zeigen dass sich durch solche medien
solche digitalen medien tatsächlich eine
strukturelle integration des digitalen
in die lehre realisieren lässt das ist
jetzt also die spannende frage und jetzt
gebe ich mal gleich ein bildschirm frei
da zeige ich ihnen jetzt mal was gleich
dazu
man kann ich mich jetzt das ganze auch
online sich mal anschauen
und dazu habe ich jetzt ihnen auch ein
paar beispiele die ich ihnen zeigen
möchte und zwar zum einen das sogenannte
blockseminar das ist ein experiment
gewesen aus dem jahr 2016
und da habe ich eben den versuch
unternommen
meine teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
selbst beiträge erstellen zu lassen auf
dieses blog es gegen zum thema
philosophische theorien des lebens und
alles wurde miteinander vernetzt hier
sehen sie eine schlagwort wolke wenn sie
dann auf ein beitrag geklickt haben dann
konnten sie davon immer weiter gehen das
heißt sie konnten dann von begriff zu
begriff springen und man hatte so ein
kleines wiki system integriert und hatte
am ende ja auch ein kleines internes
wiki das ist ein beispiel ein anderes
beispiel ist der sogenannte wiki seminar
das war aus dem jahr 2016
da habe ich versucht diese struktur des
hypertext es noch stärker zu integrieren
so dass man hier dann als seminar
leistung einen kleinen wickie artikel
erbringen konnte und am ende hatte sich
dann sehr schönes kleines internes wiki
ergeben
zur frage dieses seminars das war in
diesem semester die frage nach dem
verhältnis von sein und sollen dann
hatte ich erwähnt gibt es youtube ich
habe einen eigenen youtube-kanal
gegründet vor einiger zeit der heißt
philo cast und er hat schon mittlerweile
weit über 2000 abonnenten und ihr sehen
sie ich stelle regelmäßige
zusammenfassung meiner seminare
wöchentlich oder auch noch häufiger auf
diese seite es gibt auch noch viele
andere formate es gibt ein interview
format es gibt
themenschwerpunkte es gibt
philosophische beiträge von studierenden
ich glaube dass youtube ein ganz
hervorragendes medium ist was ich
kulturell in die lehre einfügen lässt
warum weil youtube uns nicht nur zur
rezeption animiert sondern auch
aktiviert zur mitarbeit youtube ist für
mich ein neues medium ein meta medium
sozusagen in dem die traditionelle
unterscheidung von produzent und
rezipient wegfällt weil jeder nutzer
jede nutzerin prinzipiell beide rollen
einnimmt oder genauer gesagt fusioniert
das ist in meinen augen die zukunft
überhaupt des mediums fernsehen und das
lässt sich wie ich glaube sehr gut in
die lehre virtuell digital integrieren
ich darf auch noch erwähnen dass youtube
eine ganz tolle möglichkeit live streams
zu senden also man kann auch seine der
veranstaltung hier live streamen und die
studierenden oder die sonstigen
teilnehmer können auch kommentare live
hinterlassen auf die man eingehen kann
das ist also jetzt mal aus meiner sicht
das was ich ihn zu meinen projekten
erzählen möchte und jetzt möchte ich ihn
weitere dinge zeigen nämlich ein
buchprojekt eine buchpublikation aus der
auch meine gedanken stammen dass es in
der neuen reihe heraus gebe perspektiven
der hochschuldidaktik erschienen der
erste band methoden in der
hochschullehre und es lohnt sich auf
jeden fall da meinen blick reinzuwerfen
in meinem beitrag in diesem band gehe
ich eben auch auf die evaluation dieser
verschiedenen medien ein
das ist jetzt natürlich nur eine geringe
teilnehmerzahl 20 aber es gibt auch
schon ersten eindruck und sie sehen hier
so ein blog kommt wenn jetzt fünf die
beste bewertung ist kommt recht gut
dabei weg die app ist auch gut dass
wickie ist ordentlich und es gab sogar
push nachrichten die man hier versenden
konnte und begriffs netze also praktisch
grafische darstellung der verschiedenen
leer gegenstände kam auch gut weg einem
weiteren seminar habe ich auch noch mal
ein bisschen evaluieren lassen
und hier hatte sich gezeigt dass ich
noch viel gelernt hatte so dass jetzt
das wiki die vicky option nahezu die
beste zahl erhalten hatte und auch die
app die ich erstellt hatte hat einen
guten gutes feedback bekommen das ist
waren meine ganzen medien die ich
eingesetzt hatte ich möchte jetzt zum
fazit kommen und zwar lautet es dass es
darauf ankommt dass wir es schaffen eine
virtuelle realität der digitalen lehre
zu erzeugen
wenn wir das schaffen eine virtuelle
digitale lehre zu erzeugen dann haben
wir die medien die es momentan gibt auf
dem markt sinnvoll integriert das heißt
strukturell integriert und nicht nur
additiv nicht nur so eingestreut wie so
ein spielzeug und dann wenn wir diese
medien sinnvoll integrieren durch
hypertext durch interaktion durch
aktivierung der studierenden zb indem
sie zugleich eine rezipienten wie auch
eine produzenten rolle einnehmen dass
sie selbst eigene texte verfassen und
online über text ul verlinken wenn wir
das schaffen diese ganze viel zeit die
zahl diese bandbreite an medien
strukturell zu integrieren dann haben
wir in meinen augen ist geschafft
wirklich virtuelle digitale lehre zu
erzeugen die dem begriff der digitalität
gerecht wird